how does the past hold the key to the
Black Panther's future one scene in
wakanda Forever has an interesting
answer just beware of spoilers black
panther wakanda forever was always going
to be full of surprises given the sheer
number of plot threads that have
stretched across the Marvel Cinematic
Universe since the first Black Panther
movie between the New Black Panther and
the Mysterious villain officiating the
arrival of a whole new species of super
beings wakanda forever managed to keep
quiet about one particular appearance no
one saw coming it was a welcome surprise
and a twisted way but one that will make
a drastic impact on the future of the
MCU the shocking appearance comes when
shuri makes her journey over to the
ancestral plain much like her brother
t'challa did before her audiences and
shuri herself were likely expecting to
see a conversation with t'challa in some
form instead shuri is greeted by someone
else entirely in an encounter that puts
a dark spin on the film's themes of
dealing with grief and loss it's the
reunion no one wants it but secretly did
deep down when shuri encounters the
spirit of her late estranged cousin Eric
killmonger Stevens shuri is shocked to
be greeted by her old foe but killmonger
has an explanation he's there because of
her hunger for revenge against Neymar
and her temptation to take action in
ways that those before her wouldn't have
considered these very same tactics LED
killmonger back to wakanda for his
attempt at the throne in the first place
I'm exercising my blood right the
challenge for the medals of King and
black panther while the unexpected
encounter may have been nothing more
than a warning for sure it's one that
lingers in her mind even after she
leaves the ancestral plane she so
rattled that she even refuses to talk
about the experience to Nakia still when
it comes to choosing which black panther
helmet to use for her suit she picks one
that looks more similar to killmonger's
suited up look than her brothers
respected and beloved guys the dots and
golden streaks hint that his influence
still lingers and may continue to do so
whenever the Black Panther returns when
it comes to the future of shuri's time
as the New Black Panther killmonger's
impact on his cousin through their short
meeting on the ancestral plane might be
far from over while the film saw the
wakandan princess going back on her
original declaration to killmonger and
sparing Neymar's life instead shuri's
secret may have lasting effects the
consequences of which may manifest in
future MCU projects this type of morally
gray plot development would make shuri a
far more complex and exciting hero which
isn't to say that she hasn't proven
herself worthy already imagine if the
news were to get out that it was
killmonger that sure he saw during her
visit to the ancestral plain rather than
her mother or brother
how would it go down with the
neighboring tribes of wakanda if it was
revealed that she had gained her new
Power by speaking with the Enemy that
definitely doesn't seem like the kind of
thing mbaku would be happy about in
addition having already returned for a
surprise Cameo is there a chance that
future black panther installments could
see killmonger's Spirit Haunting shuri
in the world of the living it would give
us more time to spend with Michael B
Jordan's beloved nasty guy and would
allow for the developments of a dark
Lair to the newest protector of wakanda
for the people of wakanda death is not
the end and shuri's time as the New
Black Panther is only just beginning
[Music]